I think people will have relationships
with AI systems yeah
that's very quickly but I think it'll
get boring
I think it'll be it'd be too perfect
yeah
would you date a robot
um maybe maybe for a little bit I I
don't think it would be as fun as dating
a human though
especially if humans merge with
technology sure
fun that's an interesting word
yeah I suspect the robots would be too
perfect
but if it's
I think the the human merging with the
AI would be very interesting combo yeah
I agree
because then you wouldn't have this
laggy brain that's like forgetting
things
you would have more interesting
conversations and you would have like
all of your passions you would be able
to dive in deep to them and then come up
with really great ideas on how to
explore those ideas and research would
become more intuitive I think
yeah it's a tricky thing because you
want some like life should still have
some Challenge and it feels like a lot
of our development happens in the face
of challenge
or we just find new challenges with the
even though we gained extra abilities
we'll still find stuff that's
challenging